* Rhythmische Klänge *
Ich schaue, dass er möglichst
die gleichen Dinge tun kann wie wir.
Manchmal albert er auch etwas herum,
ist dir das nie peinlich?
Nein, das gehört zu Alain. Er ist
mein Bruder, das gehört zu uns.
Auf eine gewisse Art
konnte ich schon Kind sein,
auf eine andere
aber auch überhaupt nicht.
Wie wäre es wohl gewesen,
wenn ich mir über Teenie-Themen
hätte Gedanken machen können
und nicht schon über Leben und Tod
aufgrund der Krankheit meiner Mutter?
Was ist für dich
das Schlimmste an Mamis Krankheit?
Dass ich nach der Schule nie weiss,
ob sie hier oder im Spital ist.
Lernt man mit der Zeit,
damit umzugehen? - Mhm.
Das, was alle mögen,
legt ihr überall hin.
Du magst z.B. Pilze nicht so.
Alain, Stopp!
- Dudus!
Die drei Söhne der Familie Fehr.
Der älteste und der jüngste
haben beide das Down-Syndrom.
Ich unterstütze halt meine Brüder.
Ich schaue zu ihnen.
Und ich sorge dafür,
dass sie auf ihre Rechnung kommen.
Und du kommst auch
auf deine Rechnung?
Sicher, dafür sorge ich schon.
Für mich ist ganz wichtig,
dass Joel mitbestimmen kann,
was er möchte und was nicht.
Dass er nicht gezwungen wird,
zu seinen Brüdern zu schauen.
Von ihm akzeptieren sie es auch,
weil er ja ihr Bruder ist,
den sie täglich sehen.
Das muss hierher.
Hier ist noch nichts.
Ich habe auch Leute,
die ab und zu einspringen können.
Und man sieht es: Bei uns liegen
überall Spiele und Hausaufgaben rum.
Alain Dingsda!
Dingsda von Alain liegen herum.
Wir versuchen, es so zu machen,
dass es letztlich für alle aufgeht.
Willst du eines probieren?
- Ja. - Sie sind sehr fettig.
Ich stosse es dir in den Mund,
sonst verschmierst du alles.
Schmeckt's? - Mmh!
- Gell? - Mhm!
Jetzt würzen wir es noch etwas.
Genau.
Soll ich nachputzen?
Zeig mir die Zähne!
Noch mehr.
Na bravo!
Drück den Bauch nicht so raus!
Gut. Du kannst in dein Bett.
So kann ich.
- Super. A.
* Einzelne Akkorde *
Nein. - Doch.
- Nein, die sind nicht zusammen.
Es ist so.
Ja, ja, mach ich ja.
Dann mit dieser Hand.
- Den kann ich nicht.
Nach der anfänglichen Trauer
ist im Haus der Fehrs
der turbulente Alltag eingekehrt.
Joel ist massgeblich daran beteiligt,
dass die beiden
beeinträchtigten Brüder
an allen Facetten des Familienlebens
teilhaben können.
Alain, übst du gerne mit Joel?
Ja! Üben und gut gehorchen.
Sonst müssen wir alles
noch einmal machen.
Klavierspielen, aber anständig.
Er sagt,
ich sei manchmal etwas streng.
Er müsse gut gehorchen,
sonst müssen wir es wiederholen.
Er solle anständig spielen.
Das würde ich jeweils sagen.
So, und jetzt machst du es noch mal.
* Klavierspiel *
Gibst du ihn mir?
- Ich bin an der Reihe.
Nein, ich. Du schummelst!
Alles fällt hin.
Dann gibt es wieder Apfelmus.
* Olivier spricht unverständlich. *
Krähe.
- Krähe, ja. - (Knurrend) Krähe.
Geht ja. Super gemacht, Alain!
Au!
Ist gut? - Ja.
- Sehr gut gemacht.
Ich finde es cool, dass er zu seinen
Bedingungen Klavier spielen kann,
auch wenn es manchmal
nicht ganz einfach ist.
Ich finde es schön,
dass er so sein Hobby ausüben kann.
Schau hier. Willst du probieren?
Gemüse. Das magst du doch, nicht?
Ich auch. Ich liebe es.
Noch mehr.
- Du hast Hunger, nicht?
Voila. - Vielen Dank, Mam.
- (Olivier) Bitte.
Die zwölfjährige Sarah mag sich heute
nicht mit ihren Freundinnen treffen.
Mami?
- Hm?
Kann ich alles zusammen waschen?
Und hoffen,
dass sich nichts verfärbt?
Oder sortieren.
Nein! Ich wasche alles zusammen.
Wie hast du gelernt, wie man wäscht?
- Bei Mami abgeschaut.
Und irgendwann
habe ich es selbst ausprobiert.
Hast du auch schon Dinge verfärbt?
Nein, das passiert nur Mami.
Ihrer Mutter Silvia
geht es heute nicht gut.
Die 50-Jährige leidet
an rheumatoider Arthritis,
auch Polyarthritis genannt.
Hab dich lieb.
- Ich dich auch.
Kommt ein Schub, kann die Krankheit
Silvia Ketterers Muskeln lähmen.
Dann besteht die akute Gefahr
eines Herzstillstandes.
Nein, du musst ein anderes nehmen,
ein grösseres.
Sarah packt an,
wo immer ihre Hilfe gebraucht wird.
Konflikte haben Tochter und Mutter
deswegen schon längst keine mehr.
Früher hatten wir.
Was heisst das?
Wolltest du früher nicht helfen?
Nein,
man konnte mich nur damit strafen,
dass ich nicht helfen durfte.
Du wolltest also helfen,
durftest aber nicht?
Ja.
- Und wie ist es heute?
Heute darf ich helfen. Ich glaube,
Mami ist manchmal auch froh darüber.
Und wenn ein Schub kommt,
geht ohne Sarahs Unterstützung
gar nichts mehr.
Sie hilft mir bei der Körperpflege.
Was sie nicht kann, ist ...
Wenn ich nicht mehr gehen kann,
kann sie mich nicht heben.
Das macht dann mein Mann.
Aber bei der Körperpflege,
beim Anziehen,
zu trinken und zu essen geben ...
Die Medikamente bringt sie mir.
Ich kann es nur beschreiben
und sie findet es.
An diesen Tagen sind wir meist
auf dem Sofa und sehen fern.
Denn dann muss man
nicht gross studieren.
Studieren ist nicht so gut, oder?
Hmm ... Kommt ... In diesen
Situationen nicht wirklich.
Woran würdest du herumstudieren?
Ich weiss es nicht.
Und ganz ehrlich:
Ich will es auch nicht wissen.
Es steht
"eine fette Nutella-Schicht".
"Den Teig mit einer dicken Schicht
Nutella bestreichen."
Ja, dann mach es so,
wie es im Büchlein steht.
Heisst das, ich soll langsam gehen?
- Ah, du brauchst Geld.
Heute ist nicht gut.
Heute ist super.
* Sie lacht. *
Haben Sie Schmerzen?
Ja. Alles tut so weh.
20 Fr. reichen.
Sarah ist das,
was die Forschung als Young Carer,
als junge Pfleger bezeichnet.
Young Carers kümmern sich -
neben Schule oder Lehre -
um kranke oder beeinträchtigte
Eltern, Geschwister oder Grosseltern.
Neuste Zahlen belegen:
In der Schweiz sind 8 % aller Kinder
zwischen zehn und 15 Jahren
Young Carers.
Agnes Leu ist Leiterin
des Forschungsprogramms Young Carers.
Die Schweiz steht -
im Gegensatz zu Grossbritannien -
noch am Anfang der Forschung.
Das Spektrum ist enorm breit,
was es schwer fassbar macht.
Es kann sein,
dass sie das Einkaufen organisieren,
Rechnungen erledigen,
Einzahlungen machen.
Sehr oft sind es aber auch
Begleitungen auf Dienste.
Das kann ein Sozialdienst sein
oder eine andere Stelle.
Wir wissen z.B. aus Grossbritannien,
dass es einen massiven Anstieg gibt
bei Kindern,
die um die fünf Jahre alt sind.
Die leisten emotionalen Support:
trösten, da sein, begleiten.
Einfach mit der Anwesenheit
etwas weitergeben.
Und je älter sie werden,
desto mehr Ämtli kommen hinzu.
Solange es ein Ämtli ist,
ist alles in Ordnung,
denn jeder kann
sein Ämtli zu Hause wahrnehmen.
Aber die Aufgaben variieren stark.
Da müssen wir als Gesellschaft
entscheiden,
was wir noch als kindgerecht
einstufen und was nicht.
Und jetzt schön brav trinken!
Igitt, nein, will ich nicht.
Doch, der Arzt hat gesagt, trinken.
Schön trinken!
Nein, ich will nicht.
- Trink!
Du musst tun, was der Arzt sagt.
- Nein.
Das ist vielleicht besser
für deinen Nacken.
Nein, Sarah, ist total lieb gemeint.
Das Hals-Nacken-Ding da,
dein Halskragen? - Nein.
Dann siehst du nämlich aus
wie ein Hund. - (Lachend) Ja.
Aber zumindest den musst du haben,
das ist dein Schutzengel.
(Flüsternd) Danke.
Der gibt dir zusätzlich warm.
* Die Mutter lacht. *
Dir ist eh immer kalt.
Ich bin nicht dick,
ich bin flauschig.
Du musst immer
an diesen Spruch denken.
Ja.
- Immer.
Jetzt, da sie Ihnen zu trinken gibt,
macht sie sich wirklich Sorgen, oder?
Ja, jetzt ... Aber ...
Jetzt ist es so,
dass sie es etwas überspielt.
Aber wenn sie ins Bett geht,
ist die Angst wohl da und ist gross.
Tagsüber, wenn sie etwas macht,
backt oder kocht, ist sie abgelenkt.
Oha!
- Kommt's gut?
Na ja,
als wäre eine Bombe explodiert.
* Die Mutter lacht. *
Als wäre ein Hauptquartier
gesprengt worden.
Wie ist es für Sie, wenn Sie sehen,
wie sich Sarah Sorgen macht?
Wahrscheinlich fast das Schlimmste.
Weil man ja
eigentlich nicht zeigen möchte,
dass es einem nicht gut geht.
Ja. Aber im Moment
geht es halt nicht anders.
Nein!
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein!
Mami, der war mal weiss
und jetzt ist er pink.
Welcher ist das? Oh, das ist ...
- Nein!
Es duftet schon ziemlich.
- Wenigstens das.
Das war mal ein weisses Taschentuch.
Jetzt ist es auch pink.
Das muss so sein.
Wie hängst du sie auf?
Ist mir eigentlich egal,
ich habe mein eigenes System.
Mach du es doch besser!
Wenigstens tue ich was.
Ja, es ist gut! Ja, genau.
Nachher decke ich den Tisch.
- Mhm.
Geht es?
Die sehen aus wie explodiert.
Geht es wirklich?
- Mhm.
Klar.
Sarah hat die Forscher an ihrem Leben
als Young Carer teilhaben lassen.
Sarah ist typisch
in diese Rolle geraten, schleichend.
Eigentlich schon von ganz klein auf.
Sie tut es jetzt schon einige Jahre.
Sarah kann sehr gut kommunizieren,
wenn es ihr nicht gut geht
oder wenn sie sagt,
dass sie etwas nicht möchte.
Aber sie geht auch
eher mal einkaufen
als reiten, was ihr Hobby ist.
Sie ist sehr reflektiert.
Ich weiss gar nicht, ob es
den typischen Young Carer gibt,
weil jeder junge Mensch
so individuell ist
und in einer ganz eigenen Situation.
Die Belastungsfähigkeit jedes
Menschen ist so unterschiedlich.
* Fetziger Popsong:
"Chihuahua" von DJ Bobo *
Chihuahua!
* Alain singt. *
Der 17-jährige Alain
besucht eine Sonderschule,
sein 15-jähriger Bruder Joel
die dritte Klasse der Sekundarschule.
In der Freizeit ist Joel
leidenschaftlicher Hobbyfilmer.
Man sagt zwar,
dass man das nicht sagen soll.
Aber ich finde, es passt einfach.
Es ist keine Beleidigung wie Möngu.
Ich finde, Mongo passt gut.
Sie können es so
auch besser ausdrücken.
Wenn man fragt: "Alain, was hast du,
warum bist du so anders?"
Dann sagt er: "Ich bin ein Möngi."
Wenn er sagen sollte:
"Ich habe Trisomie 21" ...
Das kann er doch nicht aussprechen.
Die Hauptpersonen in deinen Filmen
sind deine Brüder.
Ja, weil ich es cool finde.
Ich versuche es so rüberzubringen:
Sie sind aussergewöhnlich,
haben etwas drauf, sind speziell.
So versuche ich es
im Film rüberzubringen.
Damit man sieht:
Wow, die sind nicht nur behindert.
Die haben auch einen Hintergrund.
So ist gut.
Kämpfen.
Ja, ihr kämpft im Garten.
- Ja. - Gut.
Vater Vincent Fehr ist Berufsoffizier
und meist nur
an den Wochenenden zu Hause.
Nimm du doch das grosse!
Damit kannst du nicht kämpfen.
Doch.
Dann musst du aber aufpassen.
Alain, ich helf dir.
Joels bester Freund Lorenzo ist oft
und gerne bei Fehrs zu Besuch.
Oli, komm helfen!
Die sind sehr laut.
Sie leben auch richtig.
Sie schämen sich nicht.
- Warum kommst du nicht?
Sie tun das, was ihnen gefällt,
was sie tun wollen.
Das finde ich einfach super,
weil sich heute viele schämen,
wenn sie etwas anders machen.
Dann tun sie es nicht.
Ich finde es schade,
den Mut nicht zu haben,
etwas anders zu tun als die anderen.
Bei Familie Fehr ist das nicht so.
Worauf willst du warten?
- Auf grün.
Auf grün? Aber wo ist denn rot?
Oben!
- Nein, das ist keine Ampel.
Doch. - Nein, wir spielen
jetzt nicht Autofahren.
Ah, ja.
- Wir kämpfen jetzt.
Ja, ja.
* Brüllen *
Nein!
Joels Eltern hätten ihm gerne
ein gesundes Geschwister
zur Seite gestellt.
Die Trauer
über den zweiten behinderten Sohn
dauerte ein ganzes Jahr -
bis zum Besuch einer Nachbarin.
Ich war im oberen Stock
und wickelte Olivier.
Da hörte ich,
wie die Frau zu Joel sagt:
"Joel, hast du Freude am Brüderchen?
Das Baby ist süss."
"Schön, hast du
einen kleinen Bruder bekommen."
Joel sagte:
"Ich hätte schon Freude."
"Würde die Mama
doch nur nicht so oft weinen."
Da hatte ich das Gefühl:
Nein, das geht nicht.
So geht es einfach nicht.
Auch wir haben eigentlich Freude
an diesem Buben.
Da kam die Kehrtwende.
Da akzeptierte ich:
Auch dieser Bub ist behindert.
Und ich kann Joel meine Trauer
und mein schlechtes Gewissen
nicht auch noch aufbürden.
Da hat sich das Blatt gewendet.
Und heute
möchte ich es nicht anders.
Die beiden haben einander jetzt und
brauchen einander vielleicht später.
Aber es brauchte wirklich
seine Zeit.
Kein Gas.
Ich gegen dich. La la!
* Unverständliche Antwort *
Während der Schulzeit
habe ich nicht so viel Zeit.
Aber Mama
ist zwischendurch im Stress,
oft gleich auf 200,
da versuche ich,
ihr das eine oder andere abzunehmen.
Aber es geht nicht immer alles.
Fühlst du dich nicht
unter Druck gesetzt,
deine Mama zu entlasten
und mehr anzupacken?
Nein.
Wir sind eine Familie, ziehen alle
am gleichen Strick, das ist logisch.
Aber ich fühle mich
nicht verpflichtet,
weil ich immer noch
meine eigenen Rechte habe.
Aber ich schaue auch gerne,
dass es uns als Familie gut geht.
Unsere Familie kommt mir vor
wie auf einer Bergwanderung:
Das Ziel ist, dass wir
gemeinsam auf den Gipfel kommen.
Das geht nur als Team,
als Mannschaft.
Joel hat die Leaderposition
und reisst alle mit.
Das hatte er schon als kleines Kind.
Er konnte die Dinge
zum Guten wenden.
Er sagte immer:
"Das ist zwar traurig, aber ..."
Er sah immer auch die andere Seite.
Denn es ist ja nicht nur schwer.
Es hat auch sehr viel Schönes und
sehr viel Lustiges und sehr viel ...
Die ganze Leistungsgesellschaft,
in der wir stehen,
und der ganze Notendruck und was man
alles erreichen soll im Leben -
all das hat bei uns
einen ganz anderen Stellenwert.
Davon bekommt Joel
auch sehr viel mit.
Das soll er
in die Welt hinaustragen können.
Anja wurde mit zwölf zum Young Carer.
Ihre Mutter
war an Hepatitis C erkrankt.
Zehn Jahre nach der Diagnose
starb sie.
Es hat mir Grenzen aufgezeigt,
die ganz persönlichen
äussersten Grenzen,
an die man eigentlich
gar nicht kommen möchte.
Aber wenn ich heute zurückschaue,
kann ich sagen,
dass ich daran gewachsen bin.
Ich habe dadurch auch
eine gewisse Stärke erlangt.
Ich glaube, es kann viel kommen.
Es braucht viel, um mich umzuhauen.
Den Haushalt führen,
kochen für die beiden Geschwister
und den voll berufstätigen Vater.
Anja musste schnell
in ihre neue Rolle hineinwachsen.
Und sie leistete noch weit mehr:
Anja unterstützte die an Hepatitis
unheilbar erkrankte Mutter
auch emotional,
indem sie ein feines Gespür
für deren Gemütslage entwickelte.
Denn die Mutter war durch
die Ausweglosigkeit der Situation
in eine Depression gefallen.
Einerseits wollte sie leben,
uns Kindern und dem Vater zuliebe.
Sie wollte eigentlich gesund sein.
Andererseits
konnte sie einfach nicht mehr.
Diese Zerrissenheit ...
Ich kann es
fast nicht anders beschreiben.
Das war wirklich schwierig.
Auch bedrückend. Ja.
Als mittleres von drei Kindern
versuchte Anja auch,
ihrer kleinen Schwester, so gut
es ging, die Mutter zu ersetzen.
Mir ist erst heute bewusst,
dass sie vieles,
was eigentlich
eine Mutter sein sollte,
übernommen hat.
Damals war mir das nicht bewusst.
Wir haben geritten, und
ich hatte immer das gleiche Pferd.
Dieses ist dann
ziemlich unerwartet gestorben.
Ich kam nach Hause und erzählte es.
Meine Mam wollte mich trösten, weil
es mich ziemlich mitgenommen hat.
Aber ich hatte ihre Nähe
in dem Moment gar nicht so gern.
Meine Schwester
hat mich dann getröstet.
Das war für mich eher das, was ich
brauchte als der Trost der Mutter.
Young Carers
agieren meist im Verborgenen.
Manchmal
ist es der erkrankte Elternteil,
manchmal
sind es die pflegenden Kinder,
die über die Situation
Stillschweigen bewahren wollen.
Im Dorf der beiden Schwestern
wurde trotzdem geredet.
Die Leute,
die etwas mitbekommen hatten,
machten ihr mega Vorwürfe.
Im Sinne von:
Sie sei eine Rabenmutter.
Halt alles Mögliche,
was die Leute sagen.
Aber das war sie
trotz allem nicht nicht.
Auch wenn sie ihre Aufgabe so,
wie man es erwartet,
nicht mehr wahrnehmen konnte,
oder nicht mehr
immer wahrnehmen konnte,
hatte ich den Eindruck,
dass wir Kinder über allem standen.
Meine Mutter ging sogar noch putzen,
obwohl sie krank war,
damit meine Schwester und ich
reiten gehen konnten.
Sonst wäre es nicht machbar gewesen.
Sie hat alles versucht,
was in ihren Möglichkeiten stand.
Jetzt habe ich alles gepackt.
- Papi, wohin musst du eigentlich?
Nach Zwickau. - Wo ist das?
- Kurz vor Dresden, Deutschland.
Musst du langsam fahren?
Bei dem Wetter
kannst du ja nicht anders.
Sarahs Vater
ist Ingenieur im Maschinenanlagenbau
und Mitinhaber einer Firma.
Immer wieder muss er
für längere Zeit ins Ausland.
Es ist nicht mehr in dem Umfang,
in dem es war,
bevor Sarah geboren wurde.
Früher war Silvia dabei.
Zu ABB-Zeiten war Silvia dabei.
Wir waren drei Monate in Shanghai,
dann vier Monate anderswo.
Damals sah es anders aus.
Das war mit ein Grund, weshalb ich
intern den Job gewechselt habe,
zuerst bei der ABB.
Ich stieg um eine Stufe auf
und musste weniger raus.
Und ich wollte das auch nicht mehr.
Und jetzt in der eigenen Firma
gibt es auch Leute,
die mehr unterwegs sind.
Ich habe das Privileg, nicht mehr so
viel verreisen zu müssen wie früher.
Aber es ist auch ein Balanceakt.
Man kann nicht alles
von zu Hause aus machen
und die Leute rausschicken.
Dafür gibt der Markt zu wenig her,
die Firma so aufzustellen.
Tschüss.
* Bedrückende Klänge *
Man ist traurig.
Ich würde lügen, wenn ich sagen
würde: "Ich gehe gern ins Ausland."
Im ersten Moment tut es immer weh.
Und man hat es selbst in der Hand.
Man hätte ja einen anderen Job
wählen können, müsste nicht gehen.
* Klagende Streichmusik *
Sind die Nächte schlimmer,
wenn Papi nicht da ist?
Ja.
- Wieso?
Man hat einfach mehr Angst um Mami.
Man weiss nie,
ob es in der Nacht kippt oder nicht.
Wenn Papi da ist, merkt er es.
Kannst du überhaupt schlafen?
Ich muss ja.
Sonst bin ich am Morgen müde.
Sie wacht oft auf.
Nicht nur,
weil sie aufstehen muss.
Ich glaube,
oft realisiert sie es gar nicht.
Sie ruft und will sicher sein,
dass ich noch hier bin.
Wenn ich rufe oder kurz zu ihr gehe,
ist es wieder gut
und sie schläft wieder ein.
Früher musste man stundenlang am
Bett stehen, bis sie wieder schlief.
Jetzt schläft sie wieder ein.
Aber sie ruft praktisch jede Nacht.
Plagen dich denn schlechte Gedanken?
- Ja.
Was für schlechte Gedanken?
Geht es gut oder nicht gut?
Ist Mami am Morgen noch da?
Hast du manchmal Angst,
dass Mami sterben könnte?
Nein.
- Das nicht, gell.
Ob sie es als Überforderung sehen,
wissen wir noch nicht.
Das Schwierige ist:
Sie wachsen hinein.
Wie geraten sie dort hinein?
Sehr oft ist es aus Notwendigkeit.
Das ist ein Unterschied
zur Freiwilligkeit.
In einer notwendigen Situation
wird es einfach gemacht.
Man überlegt oft nicht: Tue ich das
freiwillig und will ich das?
Nein, ich bin der Chef.
* Alain brummt. *
Und wir warten jetzt noch.
Tschüss, Alain.
Heute Abend ist Joel der Chef.
Ja, mach's gut, Mam. Ciao!
- Viel Spass, pass auf!
Ja, danke. Schönen Abend.
- Danke. Ruf jederzeit an.
Tschüss zusammen!
- Tschüss, macht's gut!
Alain, jetzt darfst du essen.
Wenn du fertig bist,
kannst du es ins Spülbecken legen.
Das sind meine Brüder
und ich schaue zu ihnen.
* Olivier hustet. *
Damit sie nachher ... Geht's, Oli?
Geht's? Super.
Nicht den Ellbogen aufstützen!
Beim Rülpsen die Hand vor den Mund,
sonst gibt es keine Playstation.
In solchen Situationen
bin ich sicher etwas streng,
aber bei ihnen muss es so sein.
Ich muss auf die Toilette.
Ja, dann gehst du, Alain.
Sonst geht hier nicht viel.
Alain sitzt nur herum,
wenn man nicht bestimmt ist.
Es braucht einen Befehl:
So und so machst du das, Alain!
Dann klappt es tipptopp.
Vorwärts machen, dann duschen!
Alain, du hast alles vollgespritzt.
Oli! Hopp! Oli, mach vorwärts!
Sonst gibt's keine Playstation.
Die Dusche. Mit Haaren.
- Nein. - Doch.
Vorne auch. Hier.
So ist super. Okay.
Achtung, Oli.
Den Po noch mal hoch. Po hoch!
Joel? - Ja? - Braucht
Windeln wechseln keine Überwindung?
Nein, überhaupt nicht. Gell, Oli?
- Nein. - Oli macht vieles selbst.
Aber abends muss ich etwas helfen.
- Grosser Mann.
Ja, du bist ein grosser Mann.
Nein, nicht crashen, Achtung!
Ja, genau.
- (Olivier) Ja!
(Alain) Hey!
Super, Oli!
"Jetzt rufe ich den Arzt an."
Dann gehen sie zum Arzt.
Dort müssen sie ganz lange warten.
Oh, oh!
Liselotte verteilt die Post.
Und Oli und Alain sind auch müde,
da sie heute ganz viel getan haben.
Nein, keine Party mehr.
Schlaf gut, Oli.
- Hab dich lieb.
Hab dich lieb.
Du bist ein super Bruder.
Morgen gamen.
Morgen zusammen gamen, aber
du musst gehorchen, okay? - Ja.
Ich bin unten. Wenn du
etwas brauchst, sag es. - Ja.
Ich hab dich mega lieb.
- Hab dich lieb.
Du hast es heute super gemacht.
Ich komme nachher auch schlafen.
Schlaf gut, Oli.
Dingsda zur Seite.
* Alain spricht unverständlich. *
Schlaf gut, Alain.
Nein, Alain, ich mag es nicht.
Ich wollte dich festhalten.
- Nein, du hast schon. Das reicht.
Ich hab dich ganz fest lieb.
# Schlaf, Alain, schlaf,
der Papa isch Shaun das Schaf.
# Und d Mama isch e Tintefisch
und gumpet übere Chuchitisch,
# schlaf, Alain, schlaf.
Grundsätzlich muss ich danach
noch Hausaufgaben machen.
In letzter Zeit
kam es aber weniger oft vor,
weil Mama oder Papa schauten.
Aber zwischendurch
kommt es schon vor.
Sarah besucht die 6. Klasse.
Vor diesen Dreharbeiten
wussten ihre Schulkameraden nichts
von ihrer Rolle als Young Carer.
Den Grund
für ihre zeitweilige Müdigkeit
und die Konzentrationsprobleme
kannte nur ihr Lehrer.
Sie hat noch nie
von Schwierigkeiten erzählt.
Sie weiss aber, dass sie das darf,
und sie weiss, dass wir das
sehr sorgfältig behandeln.
Sie soll entscheiden,
wann und in welcher Form
sie davon Gebrauch machen will.
Sarah hat gelernt,
dass sie in der Schule
alles um sich herum ausblenden
und sich besser
auf die Schule konzentrieren kann.
Zu Hause ist sie wohl sehr auf
die dortigen Fragen konzentriert.
Ist das eher positiv oder negativ?
Das ist ein grosser Reifeschritt,
sich auf das Hier und Jetzt
konzentrieren zu können.
"Hier stecke ich
meine ganze Energie rein."
"Auf das andere
konzentriere ich mich nachher."
Sie machen virtuelle Fenster,
das sagen sie auch.
Sie haben ein Schulfenster,
dort ist alles gut
und dort wollen sie auch nicht
über ihre Schwierigkeiten reden.
Dann gibt es ein Zuhausefenster:
Dort sind sie mit ganz schwierigen
Situationen konfrontiert,
tragen Verantwortung. Das wird eher
mit Erwachsenen verbunden.
Z.T. ist
eine gewisse Scham vorhanden.
Sie merken, dass bei ihnen zu Hause
alles komplett anders läuft
als z.B.
bei Freunden oder Freundinnen.
Deshalb wird es oft versteckt.
Oder es kann sein, dass man von
zu Hause aus Druck ausgesetzt ist,
einem unbewussten Einfluss
der kranken Person, die nicht will,
dass die Öffentlichkeit weiss,
was zu Hause abgeht.
Man muss versuchen, den Familien
nicht das Gefühl zu geben,
sie würden es nicht schaffen,
seien anders oder - noch schlimmer -
ihnen die Kinder wegzunehmen
oder mit Konsequenzen in Form
von Institutionen zu reagieren.
Das wäre extrem wichtig.
Der Ausbruch
der Krankheit ihrer Mutter
kam fast gleichzeitig
mit Anjas Wechsel in die Oberstufe.
Die Leistungen der guten Schülerin
sackten plötzlich ab.
Da schlief man vielleicht
auch nicht so gut.
Ich mochte gar nicht lernen oder
war lieber mit Freunden unterwegs.
So hatte ich einen Ausgleich, statt
mich mit der Schule zu belasten.
Und irgendwo war es mir auch egal.
Ich war damals auch nicht gerade
der gemütlichste Geselle.
Ich war sehr abweisend unterwegs,
wenn ich heute zurückdenke,
und wollte niemanden mehr
so nahe an mich heranlassen.
Mein Kopf war
mit ganz anderen Dingen gefüllt.
Ihren Lehrern und Mitschülern
erzählte Anja nichts
von der schwierigen Situation
zu Hause.
Man hat z.B.
einen Haufen zwölfjähriger Jungs.
Alle gehen in den Fussballklub.
Dann ist da einer,
der nie in den Fussballklub geht.
Die logische Frage lautet:
Wieso kommst du nie?
Mit elf oder zwölf
hinstehen können und sagen:
"Ich komme nicht, weil jemand schwer
krank ist und ich helfen muss",
ist extrem schwierig.
Über Mobbing will Sarah nicht reden.
Doch auch sie
hat ihre Erfahrungen damit gemacht.
Heute
fühlt sie sich wohl in der Klasse
und hat einigen Freundinnen
auch von ihrer Situation erzählt.
Tschüss, bis am Nachmittag!
- Bis am Nachmittag.
Doch keine
kann ihr die Sorge darüber abnehmen,
was sie nach der Schule
zu Hause antrifft.
Man rechnet eigentlich damit, ...
- ... dass mit Mami etwas ist? - Ja.
Dass jederzeit etwas passieren kann.
Ist das schon mal passiert?
Was war da los?
Ich hatte eigentlich
mit einer Freundin abgemacht,
dass sie zu mir kommt.
Aber dann war Grosi hier.
Sie sagte, dass Mami nicht hier ist,
sondern im Spital.
Die Grossmutter ist auch heute da -
wie immer, wenn Silvia Ketterer
Unterstützung im Haushalt braucht,
damit Sarah
nicht zu viel zugemutet wird.
Sie sieht, was zu tun ist.
Sie sieht das.
Und dann tut sie es.
Bei mir
muss sie nicht so viel machen.
Aber sie hilft trotzdem.
Sie räumt den Teller ab
nach dem Essen.
Soll ich das schon wegräumen?
- Wenn du willst.
Gehört das alles mir?
- Ja.
Sarah hilft klaglos.
Würde eine Haushalthilfe
sie nicht entlasten?
Ich möchte schon das Gefühl haben,
noch gebraucht zu werden.
Sonst habe ich das Gefühl, ich ...
... ich könne gar nichts mehr tun.
Wäre es keine Entlastung für Sarah?
Es wäre eine Entlastung,
aber auch das Umfeld versucht,
Sarah zu entlasten.
Wir mussten das von Anfang an.
Wir haben das aufgebaut.
Und ich habe ein extrem gutes Netz.
Das muss ich sagen.
Ich betrachte es auch nicht
als selbstverständlich.
Aber es wäre auch eine Strafe
für sie, wenn sie nicht dürfte.
Wieso ist dir das Reiten so wichtig?
Weil es Spass macht
und ich hier einfach mal ...
Weil es einfach mein Hobby ist.
Und weil ich hier einfach ...
... ich sein kann.
(Frau) Gut, super!
Hände nach vorne. Gut.
Und jetzt noch Merlin,
dann machen wir ...
Eine Runde traben, darüber, ihr
bleibt auf dem inneren Hufschlag.
Ruhig!
(Lachend) Gut.
Springt noch einmal,
dann trabt ihr aus!
Als Sarah neu zu uns kam,
war sie extrem verschlossen.
Sie sagte fast nichts,
war sehr in sich gekehrt.
Jetzt ist sie eine Weile hier
und es ist wunderschön,
wie sie sich öffnen konnte.
Man spürt,
dass sie an Sicherheit gewonnen hat
und dass sie gerne hier ist.
Gut!
Du warst etwas schnell unterwegs.
Schau, dass du nicht abkürzt.
Das innere Bein andrücken!
Ja, gut!
Die Bedürfnisse von
pflegenden Kindern und Jugendlichen
sind sehr unterschiedlich.
Ich brauche jemanden,
dem ich meine Sorgen erzählen kann.
Ich brauche das vielleicht nicht,
will nicht darüber reden.
Ich brauche ein Instrument,
auf das ich klicken kann,
damit ich
meine Notfall-Kontaktliste kenne.
Wenn Papi oder Mami zusammenbricht,
habe ich die ersten Prioritäten.
Jemand, der 18 oder 19 ist,
braucht völlig andere Unterstützung.
Der müsste z.B. in der Berufsschule
seine Arbeiten flexibler abgeben.
Anja und Vanessa wussten,
was sie gebraucht hätten,
als es ihrer Mutter
immer schlechter ging
und diese zeitweise
Trost im Alkohol suchte:
eine Ansprechperson.
Sie fragten
in einer psychiatrischen Klink nach
und erhielten den lapidaren Rat,
in der nächsten schwierigen Situation
doch einfach die Polizei zu rufen
und die Mutter einweisen zu lassen.
Es gab Situationen,
in denen es zu Hause kritisch wurde
und die mir als Jugendlicher
auch Angst gemacht haben
oder in denen man sich
hilflos fühlte.
Einmal ist sie
mit dem Auto davongefahren
und ich wusste,
dass sie getrunken hatte.
Und ...
Ich hatte Angst,
dass sie einen Unfall macht
oder dass etwas passiert.
Da habe ich die Polizei angerufen.
Sie kamen dann hierher
und haben sie abgeführt.
Letztendlich hat sich
nichts verändert - im Gegenteil.
Ähm ... Also ...
Meine Mam
fühlte sich ziemlich verraten.
Das Vertrauen
war irgendwie angekratzt.
In ihrem ganzen Gefühlschaos ...
Und dann lässt dich dein eigenes
Kind von der Polizei abholen.
In dem Moment war sie nicht
in der Lage, das zu differenzieren
und zu sehen,
dass die Tochter nur helfen wollte.
Und das bekam meine Schwester
auch zu spüren.
Jeder hat in dem Moment getan,
was er am Besten konnte.
Aber eigentlich finde ich,
sollte ein Mediziner im Spital,
ob Psychiater oder nicht,
oder ein Polizist,
vielleicht mal hinschauen und sehen:
Hey, bei denen zu Hause
läuft etwas völlig schief.
Das fandest du damals sehr lustig,
als wir ...
Anja und ihre Schwester
schafften den Kraftakt,
an der Seite ihrer kranken Mutter
ihre Berufslehren abzuschliessen.
Vanessa ging in die Pflege,
Anja lernte Floristin.
Heute -
sechs Jahre nach dem Tod der Mutter -
ist Anja ebenfalls
in Ausbildung zur Pflegefachfrau,
Schwerpunkt Psychiatrie.
In vielen Bereichen kann ich
meine Patienten sehr gut verstehen,
weil ich Ähnliches
oder z.T. das Gleiche erlebt habe,
gerade wenn es
um Verlust oder Tod geht.
Das ist ein ganz anderes Arbeiten,
als wenn man selbst nur versucht,
verstehen zu können, wie sich
das Gegenüber wirklich fühlt.
Viele junge Erwachsene,
die Ähnliches erlebt haben wie Anja,
ergreifen einen Beruf in der Pflege.
Hier,
am Berufsbildungszentrum in Olten,
arbeitet man deshalb am
Forschungsprojekt Young Carers mit.
Es geht darum, dass man
jungen Pflegenden ein Gesicht gibt,
dass man die Thematik thematisiert,
dass man sie wahrnimmt.
Mein Ziel ist ganz klar
die Sensibilisierung.
Ich erlebe es so: Greife ich
das Thema im Unterricht auf,
und sei es nur mit ein paar Filmen,
kurzen Beispielen,
sehe ich, wie es
bei den Studierenden "Aha!" macht.
"Aha, das sind Young Carers",
oder: "Aha, ich war ja selbst
auch Young Carer",
oder: "Aha, mir war gar nicht
bewusst, dass es das gibt".
Die Aha-Erlebnisse sind gewaltig.
Und die Beispiele,
die die Studierenden benennen,
sind riesig und zeigen,
wie gross das Thema eigentlich ist.
Und mit dieser Sensibilisierung
sagen viele:
"Wenn ich jetzt
zurück in die Praxis gehe
und eine Familie am Krankenbett
oder in der Psychiatrie habe
oder in der Spitex" - unsere
Studierenden arbeiten ja überall ...
"Wenn das nächste Mal ein Kind dabei
ist, spreche ich es bewusst an."
Wenn wir bei unseren Studierenden,
die in der ganzen Schweiz
in verschiedensten Bereichen
Praktika machen, erreichen,
dass sie nachfragen,
ist das Hauptziel erreicht.
Habt ihr schon ausgewertet, wie hoch
der Anteil der Young Carers ist?
Insgesamt haben wir 51
und neun sind Young Carers.
Ich hätte nicht gedacht, dass das
hier in der Schweiz passiert.
Ich habe das eher
in Drittweltländern erwartet.
Ich habe z.T. etwas Angst,
dass Young Carer negativiert wird,
Young Carer sei etwas Negatives,
da seien Belastung,
Schlaflosigkeit und Sorgen.
Young Carer kann total positiv sein.
Jugendliche, die zu Hause etwas
übernehmen, wachsen z.T. daran.
Teilweise, nicht alle.
Sie sind selbstständiger.
Die Beziehungen in solchen Familien
sind z.T. auch viel intensiver.
Die Belastung ist zwar da,
gleichzeitig haben sie aber
sehr intensive, gute Beziehungen
innerhalb der Familie,
die stärkend und wertschätzend sind.
Young Carer muss also
überhaupt nicht negativ sein.
Es gibt sehr viele gute, positiv
erlebte Beispiele von Young Carers.
Dort drüben
ist das Flugplatz-Kommando.
Joels Eltern bemühen sich,
ihrem mittleren Sohn
immer wieder
besondere Aufmerksamkeit zu schenken.
Heute unternimmt er mit Vater Vincent
einen Ausflug
auf den Militärflugplatz Emmen.
Denn Joels Leidenschaft
gilt der Luftfahrt.
Ich möchte zu SPHAIR und dort
eine Ausbildung zum Kampfjet-
oder Helikopter-Piloten machen.
Im Vergleich zu anderen
hat er eine höhere Sozialkompetenz.
Das ist sehr wertvoll fürs Leben.
Machen Sie sich nie Sorgen um Joel?
Praktisch nie,
weil ich den Eindruck habe,
dass er oft tut, was man ihm sagt.
Das war von klein auf so.
Er ist sehr diszipliniert
und gewissenhaft.
Ein vorbildlicher Sohn,
auf den ich wirklich stolz bin.
Als Pilot hast du auch Verantwortung
für dein Flugzeug, das Volk,
für das Heimatland, die Sicherheit
des Luftraums. Viel Verantwortung.
Und das haben dich
deine Brüder gelehrt? - Ja, sicher.
Ziel der Forschung ist die
Chancengleichheit für Young Carers
in Schule und späterer Ausbildung.
Es ist nicht so,
dass sie nichts erreichen könnten.
Aber manchmal nicht das,
was sie eigentlich möchten.
D.h., sie tun etwas,
das besser passt.
Z.B. wählen sie den Studienort
in der Nähe von zu Hause,
um keinen langen Weg zu haben.
Obwohl sie ein ganz anderes Studium
vielleicht mehr interessieren würde.
Oder sie suchen
einen Arbeitgeber in der Nähe,
obwohl ihnen
etwas anderes besser liegen würde.
Young Carers gab es schon immer -
und wird es immer geben.
Sarah und Joel
geben ihnen ein Gesicht.
Sie werben
um Verständnis und Wertschätzung
für Kinder und Jugendliche
in ähnlichen Situationen.
Politik und Gesellschaft
sind eingeladen,
ihnen unterstützend
zur Seite zu stehen.
Cool, gratuliere!
- Vielen Dank!
Das hast du wirklich gut gemacht.
- Merci!
Ich bin stolz darauf,
wie sie die ganze Situation managt
und sich damit auseinandersetzt.
Und wie sie versucht,
das Beste daraus zu machen.
Was wirst du deinen Kindern
oder Enkeln mal erzählen,
wie deine Kindheit so war?
Dass ich eine schöne Kindheit hatte.
Dass ich viel erlebt habe.
Und dass ich ...
... mich ausleben durfte.
Ja.
Und was passiert
mit den traurigen Momenten?
Die gehen nicht vergessen,
aber sie stehen im Hintergrund.